National Bagel day if you're ready to
try something
really unique how about a hot Cheetos
Bagel well that's one of 30 options they
have over at the bagel Nook which is
relatively new over in downtown
Summerlin Candace Charles is there live
this morning also Bagels as well that is
quite the offering you have there
Candice good morning to you
yeah Johnny it's a little
you can try some of these or one oh it
looks like more than one obviously of a
30 that you can try here at the bagel
Nick in downtown Summerlin good morning
folks now I'm gonna try one of these
soon but how about trying
hey channel eight a bagel or maybe the
one and only bow tie bagel for the one
and only Nate Tenenbaum right and I have
here with me the manager of the bagel
Nook here uh Jordan fiskenbaum thank you
so much for joining us now before I dig
into this I want to try one of the
smears here this is just one of what 35
how do you come up with all of these
UniQue Ideas well we're a franchise and
the it was a bagel look was established
in 2015 in Freehold New Jersey so it's
there and the ownership there basically
came up with all these creations
okay so I do want to preserve the eight
so I'm going to go ahead and dig into
the bow tie and now we're trying the
maple bacon smear here let's put some of
that on there for me Jordan looks
delicious okay now while I'm giving this
a try folks you gotta tell it so what is
the special deal for this Sunday for
National Bagel day we're giving uh
channel eight uh viewers a 10 discount
they just have to say Channel 8 and
they'll get the discount awesome that's
good Jordan it's really good thank you
so much you guys can only get that
special deal with us so when you come
here say news now you get the 10
discount it opens at six today so we'll
start to see some of you guys coming in
we have all the details for you and Norm
on our website newsnow.com all right I'm
gonna finish eating guys that's a great
looking bow tie could like you could
wear it as actually like
to drive around so one of those is a bow
tie oh
hi it's Nate's bow tie and then there's
our eight okay so much talent love that
thanks Candace appreciate it uh uh but I
sometimes I'll bring in bagels for the
gang and we all had our fair share of
bagels what's the what's your go-to
flavor besides the maple bacon thing
that uh Candace had and those look good
yeah you eat Bagels a lot okay
it's been a long time since I've had a
bagel I'm not gonna lie I bet you know
what mine is
vanilla basic yes because the the basic
is the thing and then you put that then
you build on it all right